die Apothekerin Ines Lorenz ist es leid
wieder einmal schaut sie in fast leere
Schränke und Schubladen so das ist
unsere amoxicillin-schublade das ist ein
standardantibiotikum für
Atemwegsinfekte da wo die gelben Zettel
drin sind das sind normalerweise unsere
Standard Lagerartikel die eben preiswert
sind die die Krankenkassen übernehmen
die sind alle nicht lieferbar und ich
weiß nicht wie lange ich die Patienten
noch versorgen kann denn in Ihrer
Apotheke fehlen rund 200 Standard
Medikamente mehrmals täglich versucht
sie online bei Großhändlern in ganz
Deutschland Nachschub für ihre Kunden zu
organisieren
alles rot heißt nichts verfügbar immer
wieder kommt es in Deutschland zu einem
Engpass bei Medikamenten im Jahr 2017
fehlten bereits 108 Arzneien doch so
drastisch wie jetzt war es noch nie
aktuell sind es 49 Experten waren schon
sehr lange
[Musik]
also ich finde es eine reine Katastrophe
wie stark die
Versorgungsengpässe zugenommen haben
innerhalb der letzten Jahrzehnte oder
Jahre es fehlt allen Ecken und Enden
also beispielsweise Antibiotika und auch
Schmerzmittel
fiebersäfte und aber auch eben
Bluthochdruckmittel Krebsmittel
eigentlich in allen Ebenen gibt es
Defizite
nicht mal die Versorgung der Kinder ist
gesichert überall mangelt es ein
fiebersäften
Nurofen unser Standard Fiebersaft für
Kinder ist zurzeit nicht verfügbar kann
sein dass man nächste Woche wieder Ware
bekommen kann aber auch nächsten Monat
erst mal passieren weiß ich nicht
für die meisten fiebersäfte gibt es
keinen Patentschutz mehr es sind
Generika die günstig produziert werden
könnten doch warum sind sie knapp
die Krankenkassen erstatten für Generika
auf Rezept einen sogenannten Festpreis
den Sie selbst bestimmen Beispiel
paracetamolhaltige fiebersäfte deren
Festpreis ist über Jahre fast gleich
geblieben der Marktpreis für den
Wirkstoff Paracetamol hingegen ist
zuletzt rapide gestiegen
[Musik]
der Pharmakonzern sandaus einer der
größten Generika-Hersteller weltweit hat
daraus Konsequenzen gezogen die
Produktion von fiebersäften für den
deutschen Markt eingestellt
wir haben die Wirtschaftlichkeit geprüft
die Nachhaltigkeit geprüft ob man das
weiter anbieten kann und sind so im
Schluss gekommen dass wir uns auf andere
Sachen konzentrieren müssen und sind in
dem Bereich entsprechend dann
ausgestiegen das Bundesinstitut für
Arzneimittel und Medizinprodukte sah
sich gezwungen auf die Notlage zu
reagieren etwa 90.000 fiebersäfte für
die Ukraine wurden auf den deutschen
Markt umgeleitet ja das sind im Prinzip
als neilmittel die in Deutschland
produziert sind für die Ukraine gedacht
sind diese nicht in die zu lassen oder
auszuliefern halte ich für ihn
diskutabel dort werden sie mit
Sicherheit gebraucht und wir müssen
andere Wege finden die versorgen
sicherzustellen und nicht durch solche
zweifelhaften Aktionen
selbst Krebsmedikamente fehlen hayriere
Oguz ist vor einigen Jahren an
brustkrebserkrankt eine Operation und
Chemotherapie hat die Hamburgerin hinter
sich damit der Krebs nicht wiederkommt
muss sie noch immer einen
östrogenblocker einnehmen Tamoxifen doch
im vergangenen Jahr war das Medikament
wochenlang nicht verfügbar
in der brustkrebs-community hast du noch
Tamoxifen konntest du dein Rezept
einlösen
wo kriegen wir jetzt Tamoxifen her ja
die Ärzte waren ratlos ja und wenn man
jedes mal gesagt bekommt gibt es zurzeit
nicht ist nicht lieferbar dann macht er
sich schon so langsam so mulmiges Gefühl
in der Magen gegen breit ja es war schon
[Musik]
bis nachher beängstigend
ihr Krebsmedikament wurde lange Zeit von
20 Herstellern für den deutschen Markt
produziert jetzt sind es nur noch zwei
einer davon ist Hexal der Hersteller
gehört inzwischen zum Pharmariesen
sandos
das ist mit Sicherheit eine kritische
Situation
oder kam etliche unserer Mitbewerbern zu
dem Schluss dass sie nicht mehr anbieten
können zu den Preisen die entsprechend
von den Krankenkassen bezahlt werden wir
kriegen wir kriegen momentan 8 Cent für
eine Tablette für eine Tagesdosis
Tamoxifen das ist weniger wenn Kaugummi
der Konzern hat zwar reagiert und die
Produktion kurzfristig hochgefahren doch
langfristig ist die Versorgung
keinesfalls gesichert auf dem
pharma-markt herrscht ein ruinöser
Wettbewerb die Hersteller Bohlen um
Rabattverträge mit den Krankenkassen und
gewähren enorme Preisnachlässe die
Krankenkassen verhandeln mit den
Generika Hersteller und der Generika
Hersteller der am preiswertesten ist der
bekommt zum Schluss den Zuschlag
verhandelt wird im Verborgenen zum Teil
mit dubiosen Angeboten wie das
Online-Magazin Apotheker attok
aufgedeckt hat teilweise um die 99%
Rabatt und der Konzern glennmark der AOK
Baden-Württemberg für mehrere Wirkstoffe
ein besonders drastischer Fall wenn 99%
Rabatte vereinbart werden dann ist
vollkommen indiskutabel das heißt der
Markt wird systematisch kaputt gemacht
durch solche Aktionen weil es muss doch
eigentlich klar sein dass die Firma
dadurch andere vom Markt verdrängt
Nachfrage bei der AOK Baden-Württemberg
die gibt keine Auskunft zu den
Vergabeverfahren genauso wie glennmark
auf ihrer Homepage wirbt die Firma aber
mit zahlreichen AOK Rabattverträgen
[Musik]
Folge dieses Preisdumpings der
allergrößte Teil der Arzneimittel wird
inzwischen billig in China und Indien
produziert
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach versprach
schon im Dezember per Gesetz
gegenzusteuern wir haben wir wirklich
ein System genutzt wo die Preise so
stark gedrückt worden sind dass nur noch
der billigste Hersteller eine Chance am
Markt gehabt hat wir sind jetzt zu weit
gegangen
Lauterbach will unter anderem die
Preisschraube lockern aber erst dann
wenn sich ein Engpass abzeichnet
mit diesem Gesetz glaube ich können wir
die
Lieferengpässe auch langfrist und zwar
langfristig und zwar in allen Bereichen
der Generika Versorgung deutlich also
entschärfen außerdem will er das
Pharmafirmen wieder mehr in Europa
produzieren was allerdings nicht so
einfach ist denn wir brauchen
Zwischenprodukte wiederum aus China also
ganz unabhängig zu werden von China ist
quasi nicht möglich
selbst die wirkstoffsynthese die ist ja
auch alles ist alles ausgesorgt ist
alles ausgelagert wir hängen am tropft
der Asiaten und wenn in China wieder
Corona ausbricht oder die Inder sagen
wir brauchen unser Paracetamol für
unsere Leute dann sind wir halt die die
hinten anstehen
und so muss ich Apothekerin Ines Lorenz
über jede einzelne Packung freuen die
geliefert wird also Penicillin zwei
Packungen ja wie lange reicht das für
Sie jetzt das Wochenende also drei Tage
an den Lieferengpässen wird sich so
schnell nichts ändern trotz seiner
Ankündigung hat der Gesundheitsminister
bis jetzt nicht einmal einen
Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt dafür hat Herr
ihre augus kein Verständnis ich würde
mir ehrlich gesagt mal wünschen dass
Herr Lauterbach irgendwann in der
Apotheke steht so wie ich und sagen
Medikament nicht kriegt und dann halt
alle möglichen Apotheken abklappern muss
und
feststellen muss ich kriege mein
Medikament nicht und vielleicht auch so
ein bisschen die Verzweiflung dann spürt